the challenge for world leaders reduce  global warming by 2 degrees any PS and  members of national parliaments met with  commissioners to prepare the 21st  century climate conference which is to  be held in paris at the end of the year  alapaha Walter William sheltering  terrorists in the Alton device industry  ali khamenei stati uniti lishchyna  lyndia quindi written llamo que si  possono ESO le condizioni / 5 own accord  o global carry worthy too deep but when  economic crisis hits is the environment  still a priority from a European  perspective environment has dropped a  bit but I think that's really a pity  because if there is one potential for  jobs and growth it is a green economy it  is economy that is less import  dependence and is reusing the resources  we have the challenge in Paris will be  to convince developing countries to  reconcile their growth with their need  to protect the environment